Why are we still here?
Just to suffer.
Every night, I can feel my comments.
And my subscribers
And even my channel
The comments I've lost
It won't stop hurting.
You feel it too don't you?
I'm gonna make them get back our past.
The comments on YouTube.
I'm gonna bitch about the comments on YouTube once again.
In 2014, I made the video but deleted the comments.
look at that beautiful face
nothing nothing has changed since that
date
look at look at him 2014 00 and then
after meetings and meetings with you
2016, let's fix the comments. But they're all
still here they're all bullshit higher
here's how it looks like when i checked
the commons is like oh I uploaded a new
video
oh I wonder what people say about it
because they have worked a lot on it and
I want to know what people think these
are the top comments on my life video
cued a pay
hello gross we have finally passed 15
family members package emoji now I got a
small debris for you search periods 9230
on google but it's fucking Beverly Hills
oh and while we're at it by the way I
mean to change topic but can you guys
shut the fuck up about my hair
ok I'm going through a rough period
right now we're okay this kind of tweet
are not funny this is clearly you know
it has my avatar that has my name that
is definitely my name is getting smart
it's like myself it's getting even
smarter and I know I know what you're
thinking what happens if you google pends 9320
FORSUBS welcome to PewDiePie's give away Ainsley!
AINSLEY LOOK AT ALL THAT SHIT I'M GIVING AWAY
fuck now i wouldn't give it that way i'm
a fucking Swedish bastard i'm not gonna
give away shit fuck you
HOLY shit i'm giving away Kylie lip kit
*GASPS* there's always 368 left
I like how it says copyright PewDiePie
team 2016 What the fuck is
PewDiePie Team 2016
What is your gender
Did PewDiePie just assume my gender
*TRIGGERED*
this is disgusting, you might trick my fans
All you want, but assume their gender
FUCK YOU gender is just a social construct
That is my core message
everyone knows that, this is clearly
fake Ainsley, I'm starting to believe that
*Checks spam bot name*
PewDeiPei is not actually me!
OH MY GOD
What if PewDeiPei isn't me?
Then who am I?
Why are we still here just to suffer
If this is the comments
Then every night I can feel my leg (What)
the second comment is Joanna from Joanna
Stannard. Joanna Stannard? More like
Joanna No Stannard (Pewds Pls) BITCH
*ROASTED* *EXPLOSION*
Hey, if you're gonna be a fake girl at least be a fucking
girl and not some cartoon fucking image
Jesus Christ and that AT LEAST if you're
pick a girl pick some fucking nice Waifu
You know like something i can be
like oh shit well I'd you know if that
was it that cartoon lady was a
real person that would definitely you
know fuck so basically my comments right
now are just being used instead of uh me getting
comments from your bros that you can't (British accent?)
That you spend time you talk to me and I want
to know what you're saying but instead
of that all I'm getting is the fucking
top comments fucking spam all three of
them I got a little surprise for you UGH
I've said this before and I said it two
I said it three years ago let me pick if I
want people to use top comments or not.
If we could just turn off top comment
this wouldn't happen i could just read
the comment as they go
that used to be the case
*Looks at YouTube settings*
Here
Allow comments, newest first.
Oh wait so I can change it?
this didn't used to be a thing
before you could this is a fucking thing
with YouTube like they have all these
features that they changed but they
don't tell anyone how the fuck am I
supposed to know about Jesus Christ
every time is like I make this rant video
and then YouTube is like: but we have all
these features that you're bitching about
Oh shit it fucking works
what the fuck why did no one tell me?!
there's a point to this video which very
much ties into what I'm about, what I'm
talking about right now but first let's
review a couple things that I think you
might find interesting
so here's my comment section majigger
thing so there's 1,000,000 1.3 million
roughly comments held for review and then
there's 240,000 marked likely as
spam and Lo Derryyy wrote loved it
youtube is like SPAAAMM *Laughs*
I love this guy
Joao Nsita he's been automatically
flagged as spam on youtube he says
want to know what a modern black man
gets up to on his date click here
You know fuck you YouTube. How dare you
mark Joao Nsita as spam
I happen to very much would like to
know what a black modern black man gets
up to on his date, and you know what I will click
here one view huh
guess it's only me Ainsley you're you're a
modern black man why don't you tell ok
let's watch
oh yeah
god I love me just be loaded on a better
day to have a wonderful of me
oh I just say
*Subscribes*
*Snorts*
look how hard he tried to comment ok he's
everywhere. YouTube keep blocking him
it's not right it's not right
damnnit
These aren't even bad comments
like why are you and edgar so cute
nice, nice profile pic, love your show
you're so good at art like why are these
being held
like most of these are not even spam
I don't understandx2
there's also still these girls posting
in the comments like hey subscribe to my
channel and I'll show you my titties
I found one yesterday, her name is JaleVFX
and I think that's pretty cool you know
she's not just some random girl posting
nude on the internet but she also had
combined that with video effects
I think, what a great fucking idea she's not
just being a random slut on the internet
she's actually taking her talent and
good looks
actually if you're going to create a
fake profile around the girl at least
pick somewhat attractive girl, or at least
a photo that isn't like
Like this
You know, i don't i would use this is my
dating photo that Jale AF via shut the
fuck up ok 4,000 people fell for
this fucking scam. There's porn on the internet
let's not keep it on youTube
4000 people wanted to see JaleVFX
naked ok well let's click on
her new nude
oh how about that since that's an ad
gotta wait five seconds 5321 come on
come on
come on come on come on come Ahh FUCK God
dammit I really thought that would work
this is what the comments is taking up
instead of reading what you bros write
and that's what's something I truly
Care about
Youtube surely must understand it
Ainsley is so upset he fell over
Jesus Christ after last rant video i did
I basically requested that you could
just have moderators because i can delete
my comment and i can clean them up but i
don't really have time to go through the
literally thousands of comments to make them
better and let you guys
I've seen you bros complain a lot over the comments not being
good and filled with spam but you
can't help out but now you can it's
time to change
youtube finally added moderators
actually Ring Ring, Ring Ring
what's that youtube it's been there
all along it's another one of those features
that you didn't tell anyone about
So I look like a whiny ass hole again
ok I'm sorry okay love you love you too
okay bye, bye-bye
MODERATORS
Do you want to be a moderator for the Poodiepie channel?
Ainsley is first rank moderator
I am, General
Ainsley, is General Lieutenant
you guys if you are moderator you
got the chance instead of being a fan
leak
do you want to be a captain
for the Poodiepie channel well now's your chance
comments down below and
explain to me why you want to be a
moderator basically we're just going to
get a militant structure
of the whole channel so that finally in
2017 we can in fact invaded Norway i am
getting tired of Norway's bullshit and
I'm starting to think that YouTube in
Norway are the same thing so now captain
comment down below if you want the
great honor of being a moderator on this
channel me the general will, uh
choose wisely based on a couple things
number one great look you need to be
attractive number two I don't want to
moldy ass fucking who I need to be
moderator because I have been a fan
of Poodiepie for a very long time no no
none of that. there's no way i can actually know
okay? So i don't want your fucking lie just
tell me something really really really
really great about me
number three what is Ainsley's real name
if you can answer these three questions
i will pick you as a moderator, as a captain
And we can finally,
#MakeYouTubeGreatAgain
Actually number four this needs to be your
profile picture
those are all the requirements
Is everything understood? Great, now go forth
my children and if you want to shine
like the Sun you have to burn like it
and we will burn
these shitty commentary (just like yours felix) we will cleanse the
YouTube comments section it will be
purer than no other race I mean comments
section
This is getting weird. isn't it?
alright well that was this video
hopefully it's the last one I'll ever get to
do about comments because it's getting old
but anyway why are we still here click
on another video just to suffer every
night, I can feel like Ainsley
Also, since
Ainsley is general, i want you guys to know that
if you get a PewDiePie rank,
we take very good care of our own very
(Pewds what are you doing)
Very good care ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡° )